ce qui était très intéressant dans cette
audition c'est que les sénateurs ont
fait parler d'autre chose que uniquement
du régalien on a parlé de santé on a
parlé de famille on a parlé des cols on
a parlé d'écologie on n'a pas à l'être
une réalité donc on a abordé des sujets
qui malheureusement ne sont pas encore
abordé dans les débats télévisés donc
c'est vrai que là les bras principales
préoccupations des français c'est le
pouvoir d'achat et c'est la sécurité
mais dans un projet présidentiel il faut
pouvoir aussi aborder d'autres sujets la
désertification médicale la lutte contre
le décrochage scolaire qui seront des
grandes causes de mon quinquennat on va
approcher le feu au débat
sert que le problème c'est qu'après les
journalistes posent leurs questions donc
effectivement moi j'ai voulu évoquer
dans le dernier débat le défi climatique
je l'évoqué longuement le long ici parce
que ça fait partie des défis cruciaux
pour les générations futures tout autant
que l'est de la france où tout donc que
l'insécurité ou l'immigration
donc ce défi climatique il faut prendre
à bras le corps et moi je veux être une
présidente écologiste l'écologiste des
solutions
[Musique]